hello there ladies and gentlemen welcome
to
this episode of into the impossible
podcast i'm your host
your fearful host in this time of
pandemic podcasting brian keating
co-director of the arthur c clarke
center for human imagination
and our guest today is none other than
seth godin one of the most
interesting charismatic influential
individuals i've ever had the pleasure
of interviewing
on this podcast uh today we're going to
learn about seth's
phenomenal new book called the practice
as well as
his understanding of science and science
fiction including quantum gravity
and his questions and his appetite for
intellectual
uh curiosity and even in science and
science fiction
uh really knows no bounds it's truly
rapacious as they say
uh so seth is a truly influential
individual
he's affected me so well it was such a
treat to get to talk to
this living legend and may he live and
write and
and do well uh continue to do well
you'll also learn about his passion and
even his connection to our namesake sir
arthur c clarke which i never knew
and so today there'll be a couple of
exclusives that you'll learn about seth
but most of all you'll get a sense of
this remarkable
mental magician and the things that he
does to
improve the lives literally of millions
of people so sit back
enjoy this episode of seth godin of the
into the impossible podcast please don't
forget
to like comment subscribe um tattoo no
do
uh whatever you can leave a review
especially i read them all
and they really help us in the
all-important
algorithmic uh ascension that we are
aspiring to
on the arthur c clarke center for human
imaginations into the impossible podcast
sit back enjoy the ride
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
and uh it's a treat to have uh seth
godin
on the podcast a legend in many
different ways an inspiration
a mentor via remote mentorship
and uh as you know on this podcast we
talk about
painful divorces embarrassing stories
from junior high school
and now i can't imagine how many
podcasts you've done actually i know how
many you've done because you posted on
your blog
seth how do you find the time to do
everything you're doing in this hectic
time
of life well first i'd like to say that
i'm a pretend scientist so talking
actual science with actual scientists is
is thrilling for me
i don't go to meetings i don't watch
television so i get seven or eight hours
other people don't get
uh the company i started at kimbo is now
an independent b corp so i don't have
any employees
and i think talking to people who are
passionate
about what they do who have an audience
that's sizable enough to make it worth
it
is a privilege so i keep doing it it's a
great pleasure to have you here i want
to just read a very quick biography
since a lot of my
audience uh you know is comprised of
scientists but not all we've had on
many different guests and all different
um in all different disciplines but i
just want to give a quick intro to seth
you founded several companies including
including yoyodyne and squidoo
your blog is one of the most popular in
the world you're the host of the akimbo
podcast which i've been listening to for
many years now
and you're the author of several books
including linchpin tribes the dip
purple cow and what to do when it's your
turn and it's always your turn
and of course today the practice
shipping creative work
and uh so first of all mazel tov
congratulations on the publication of
another book i devoured it
in uh in just 52 sittings which is about
three sittings per
per chapter of the book uh it's pretty
impressive you did that
i said to my wife you know uh god only
needed ten commandments but you know
seth has got 230. um so you've done so
many things
i want to know uh my podcast uh we often
talk about alien
alien abductions we're not allowed to
talk about the alleged alien abductions
that i've participated in but
uh i want to know if an alien wakes up
seth godin 3am
shakes you and says who are you what do
you answer
you've completely distracted me with the
alien part so
to a human i would say i'm a teacher and
i've been a teacher since 1977.
i like turning lights on for people i am
curious
but then i develop a point of view and
what i have found is the thing i am
hooked on
is turning on a light for people and so
you know i invented email marketing but
i didn't stick around long enough to
start mailchimp or turn it into a 10
billion dollar industry
because that wasn't my goal my goal was
to say here's this thing
let me teach you how it works and then i
went and taught the next thing
i want to start with a quiz i'm a
professor as you know a university
professor and we like to give quizzes
i've done extensive research on the
following do you know what the two most
common words are
preceding it was the best thing that
ever happened to me
no i failed
it's actually i failed and i want to i
want to get that in place so you talk
so much about about overcoming these
obstacles
which i want to get into how your book
which you wrote you know primarily for
people shipping creative work
and uh but i i think it applies a lot to
scientists and
yeah to the many things that a scientist
has to do that an entrepreneur does
the only difference being we don't make
any profit on our sales
uh we don't work 40 hours a week uh if
that would be a nice
low number a vacation week for us and uh
and we don't really have you know a
board to answer to but all the other
things are very similar and i want to
know
uh you talk about you know kind of your
destiny is in your own hands
but as academics let's first start with
that uh it wasn't in my hands to get
into
the the college that i got into it
wasn't in my hands to get into the
graduate school the postdoc
the assistant professorship the faculty
job and then
eventually to be you know part of a team
that could have won a nobel prize
um how do you deal with gatekeepers in
the sciences
versus creative work with the
gatekeepers in here
well there's a lot nested in that um
first
you know i studied with a nobel
prize-winning physicist at tufts
i took as much science as i could in
high school and i will tell you
that labs in high school and college do
not teach you science
they teach you pretend science how to be
a cog
in the science industrial complex but
there is zero room to actually do an
experiment
where you don't know what's supposed to
happen
and that's a real shame because i can
teach a six-year-old how to do that
and if you want to do good science you
have to do experiments
you're not sure are going to work
because all the ones we're sure are
going to work have already been done
before
and so that's the essence of the word
creative in my title shipping creative
work
it is not about design or prettiness or
painting or opera it is creative work is
the work of a human that's generous
that connects us that might not work
and i would argue that every single
scientific breakthrough i am aware of
fits that description so now you nested
into that this idea that there are
gatekeepers
and there certainly are you can't get
access to a cyclotron or
something to test the higgs boson if you
don't get someone's approval you can't
just do that in your garage
but most of the slots
are allocated somewhat randomly
i i used to be
a volunteer contributor at the
engineering
school admissions office at tufts and
um of every 10 people who applied six of
them were good enough to get in
and one did so what they should do is
write a letter to the six
and it should say you were good enough
to get in and we randomly picked someone
else
but they don't do that and that's a
mistake because it
makes people who get picked think they
got picked on merit when they did it
all of which is a way of saying there
are some slots
left for people who pick themselves
those slots go to people who without
getting picked
did something off the charts and if you
can do something off the charts
you've got the shortcut to be you know
to be a professor you've got the
shortcut
to to have your own lab because you
develop the mindset not of
what do you want me to do but i did this
what do you think and
that's where we need science to go when
you think about
scientists as really replicating the
failure mechanism the scientific method
is really one of iteration after failure
it's built in that you're going to fail
or that you're going to prove somebody
else wrong
maybe someone else that was held up and
idolized many decades or centuries ago
i want to talk about um yeah this
process of of scientific creation
because i think
we as physicists so i get to study the
13.8 billion year old universe some of
my colleagues down the hall
study exoplanets orbiting around other
suns
other colleagues study the intricacies
of the atom
the nucleus the periodic table behind me
over there
and and yet if you ask somebody to name
a scientist they almost can't do it or
they'll name someone who's dead
or they'll say neil degrasse tyson who's
a wonderful marketer
but he's not a scientist in the sense
that you know my colleagues are
and i want to ask you how do we improve
uh the marketing skills of a scientist
because we have the greatest material
ever created
by god or whoever you like and we are
not effective at communicating it as
evidenced by the fact that nasa's budget
is less than what humans
on earth spend on lipstick in a six
month period
all right well those are two again
nested questions if you
if you asked a hundred people uh to name
me
without telling them my name they only
one or two could do it
so this idea that you have to be more
famous than neil degrasse tyson is nuts
you don't no the goal of marketing is
not to serve the largest possible
audience is to seek the smallest viable
audience
so the mistake that scientists have made
through the years is not
figuring who are the nine people or the
90 people or the 900 people
they need to market to instead they say
wow
look how famous mr rodriguez is i should
be that famous that's
no don't do that find the specifics
and be famous to them i don't think
stephen hawking being famous
did very much for stephen hawking's
ability to accomplish anything that he
wanted to accomplish
but if you haven't seen the video of him
and paul rudd playing quantum chess
it's absurd like where did that come
from
anyway i digress
so then the question is why is nasa's
budget smaller
than the budget for lipstick well there
are two reasons for that
one because people who buy lipstick get
more out of it than they do from paying
taxes to go for nasa
that's just human nature and nasa's
source of funding
uh is always going to be fraught unless
they figure out how to hook
into human nature so
during the uh 1960s
four percent of the u.s budget the
entire government's budget
went for the apollo mission four percent
while we were fighting the most
expensive war in our history
why because you can look up in the sky
and see the moon
and every time i tell the story about
the day i met neil armstrong
i get weepy but i don't feel that way at
all about something that's picking up
rocks on mars
because it's just not a good story so
that's why
the money isn't there right but i think
the real challenge
that scientists have
as we've industrialized science is they
are forgetting to be scientists
there isn't enough failure it doesn't
need to be
rocket science failure you know let's
let's come up with something no one ever
thought of failure
but there are so many places where
science can show up with
actual replicatable insightful
experiments
that will make things better but instead
they get hung up on correcting the
science that came 10 years before
right the flip side of course of failure
is achieving great success
and i want to have a read you a quote
from nobel laureate
uh t.s eliot he said the nobel is a
ticket to one's own funeral
no one has done anything after he got it
uh you talk about seductive the
seduction of cinecures can you
first define a cinecure for those uh out
there who
may not know it and why is it bad to
have these
you know impetuses uh if you will that
animate
many of my colleagues and i freely admit
myself as a younger version to win
awards
that and indicate and and show the
success not the failures that we're
responsible for
so is that is that a uh a real one
this one yeah oh oh you've got one too
uh no this one this one was edible back
in 2010 when i was in stockholm to
ah it's gelt it's gelt exactly
that's right is your is yours magic
whoa close up magic anyway resume
wow anyway an exclusive for seth godin
on the into the impossible podcast
a cinecure is a safe place to hide it is
uh where the woodpecker hangs out on the
tree and the fox can't get them
cinder cures we probably
evolved to like because you're more
likely to have grandchildren if you can
find a cynical
and it probably doesn't
align with our dreams to have a sinicure
so
t.s eliot is correct but i think he
missed something which is
the purpose of the nobel is not to win
the no bell it's to chase the nobel
because if you act like someone who
wants to win a nobel prize
you're more likely to do the science you
ought to be doing
and one of the you know i've i've given
a thousand presentations live
and in at least 300 of them i show a
picture of the solvay conference from
1927.
and in it are 29 scientists uh
einstein's there marie curie's there
niels bohr is there it said
that heisenberg is there but it's
uncertain whether he was or not
and of the 29 people in the picture
17 won the nobel prize and
almost all of them won it after 1927.
that's the punch line right because the
punchline is heisenberg but the other
punch line is
that you won the nobel prize because you
got invited to solve a
not the other way around and so you want
to live your life
so that you get invited to solve that's
how you win a nobel prize
and the way you get invited to solve a
is by being shunned and criticized
by people who do industrial science
because you are committed to doing
creative science right and it said that
there are nobel prizes that bestow
uh honor beatification upon the
recipients and then there's a converse
of those people that you named arguably
the einsteins etc
they gave prestige to the nobel prize
and
in terms of this you know i i saw a
picture you know from time magazine
i think it was the day after einstein
died in 1955
and it was an image of the earth and a
giant sign and said einstein lived here
and we do tend to idolize of course and
and the power of awards
is a tangible one you talk about this um
quite frequently but um but i think you
know it is true that
that there are very few kind of tangible
perks like once academics
who are used to being graded and sat and
acted and
prodded and poked and competing against
each other to get to this top level
once we run out of grades there's almost
like this this
this sense of disorientation we're not
being graded anymore i'm a full
professor
like uh but maybe there is there is this
nobel prize and i could win it and i was
told to get tenure
i have to be in the running for it which
is a whole other story but i think
uh you know in writing those things are
all up here but the cohort
the cohort uh benefit of having this
cohort that you talk about
of critics that are honest that won't
just tell you everything is great but
they won't tell you that everything's
crap either can you talk about the value
of you know the talmud says acquire
yourself a teacher
a student and a friend so of those three
the the friend the the the generous
critic
tell us about the importance of that
yeah so i think it's really important
that you start the keating prize and you
invite
10 people who are at the prime of their
career to be in a circle that's going to
meet by zoom
every week to make a promise to the
other people and give an update as to
how they're doing on the promise
because they don't want to get kicked
out and if they stay for a year
their career will be transformed you can
organize it you don't need
to send someone 765 000 kroner you can
just say
you're in you're in the circle and
that's why i wrote a book because a book
you can hand
to other people and say we're going to
do this thing together
and you know when i think about fermi
sitting around
talking to other scientists about aliens
i really wish i could have been at that
table because that
feels to me like a big part of what we
need more of in modern science
and you know back when i went to ted i
was lucky enough to
to meet and hang out with some
scientists there and
unfortunately once scientists get too
famous
they start playing the role of
scientists instead of actually being
scientists
and i think that helps and i fought
really hard not to do that with my
career
and that's why i have to keep you know
no sequels for me
because i don't want to be a version of
that i want to say well this one might
not work
so speaking of my network can i ask you
a question of course this is
right it's sort of complicated so let me
warm my way into it
if uh i had a
photon torpedo and i could blow up the
sun
it would take eight minutes for people
on earth to realize it was gone
right how long would it take the gravity
waves to not affect the earth
yeah that's the same exact speed so
einstein encrypted in his
1915 laws that that also revealed what
we call general relativity which i
consider the pinnacle of culture
and i'll talk to you about science as a
part of culture
in a minute but yes the the same speed
that governs the propagation
of light waves also is manifest in the
speed of propagation of gravitational
waves
so we wouldn't actually notice it
because of the gravitational waves i
mean there's only a very tiny
number of detectors that can actually
sense a gravitational wave
which distorts a proton just by the half
earth billionth
of the time we would notice it because
the earth would stop orbiting the sun
yeah we would go off on centrifugal on
our centrifugal way
that's right all right so i can block
light waves superman reference
with a sheet of lead correct what do i
need to block gravity waves
oh that was such a good question
actually it brings up one of my heroes
and i'll talk about hero worship this is
one of our heroes that we'll talk about
this is galileo galilei and this is the
other one carl sagan when we get to
books
i'm going to talk to you about a quote
that he said about books but galileo is
my favorite scientist because
he was the most flawed individual with
these great uh talents so he wrote a
book called
as you may have heard the dialogue the
famous dialogue on the two chief world
systems
all right i have to read it i haven't
didn't know anything about that this is
this book will change your life in this
book he talks about the dunning-kruger
effect
he writes prose poetry but this book
seth it wasn't originally going to be
called the dialogue on the chief world
systems that's a pretty cool name right
but guess what its original title was it
was on the flux and reflux of
tides and the earth's rivers and ferns
that that's just a must read right you
you could not put that down i mean i
think the second choice was harry potter
but that was taken
right it was the practice part two but
in this or part one
in this book he talks about uh the proof
in his mind that the earth went around
the uh
uh when around the sun was generated by
the tides on earth which are caused by
in his proclamation the sloshing of
vodka in a glass
as it spun and oriented and revolving
that was proof guess what that we call
it we call it confirmation bias
he so wanted to prove this was right he
was willing
to destroy the power of the title and
the ideas that he had in there we now
know
that the tides on the earth have nothing
to do with the earth's rotation or
revolution and instead
are caused by the gravitational
distortions on the earth's surface
caused by the moon this tiny little
object so you're absolutely right
gravity goes through everything
and it's unstoppable as far as we can
tell because what it does
is it distorts the connections between
space and time it fundamentally alters
how matter us travel or light travels
throughout uh throughout the universe so
that is its power the gravitational
power gravity's power is by virtue of
its all-penetrating nature
that's no superman no uh or spider-man
in the in the spider version okay so
wait so but
i and then i will get back to our topic
in here but
light is a particle and a wave correct
gravity which goes exactly the same
speed yep
is not a particle it may be a particle
that is the holy grail
of so-called theories of everything
which uh we speak about often on the
into the impossible podcast we're trying
a particle then
something could stop it if it's a
particle
in a certain domain it would manifest uh
the gravitational force via the exchange
of what's called a boson like the higgs
boson but called a graviton
to in order to to test that hypothesis
the golden theory
you would have to go to the only epochs
or places where gravity's quantum
properties are manifest
the singularity that may or may not be
present inside of a black hole
and the singularity that may or may not
have happened in the early
portion of the evolution of our universe
we don't know those properties
because of a simple reason we don't even
know if anything infinite exists right
i mean seth have you ever seen a
triangle
an actual triangle yeah no no they don't
exist
right they don't exist in the physical
world they exist in the world of ideas
have you ever seen something of infinite
temperature infinite density
an infinite uh and uh infinite extent
infinitesimally
so i wrote i read about hilbert's hotel
which fascinated me yes and that got me
on a whole other buckle anyway i got 15
minutes left
let's go back so let's keep going okay
so i want to talk to you as i said the
uh the practice contains
over 230 commandments i want to talk to
you uh
about about the role that religion plays
or doesn't play in your life
you should know that many many orthodox
rabbis uh quote your
uh your your sermons and their sermons
uh what role does judaism play in your
life or has it played in your life or or
do you envision it playing in in in
somebody's life
yeah i try very hard not to be a guru
i'm just trying to talk about things
that have nothing to do with me
so i don't talk about my kids i don't
talk about spirituality don't talk about
my family
okay good um i wanted to ask you uh if
you knew
what was atop the washington monument in
washington dc what medal
did they choose in the 1800s to crown
the cap of the washington monument
it's weird because i know that i used to
know this
it would take less bits to just know it
yes but i just know that i used to know
it
i i'm gonna say palladium i can prove
that you know because i think i learned
this from you
in a podcast from a decade ago but it's
aluminum or aluminium
and the reason why is because that used
to be considered valuable and that
people
had a great deal of difficulty just you
know purifying aluminum
and so they put that up there now
imagine alien comes again again with the
aliens keating
so we used to believe that that was much
more valuable than gold and
i think uh someone discovering that now
wow this can of coors light at the top
yeah do you know why do you know why
they smelt so much aluminum in iceland
uh i think they have a lot of bauxite
they have no box like
they have one box not one box no box
no box they have to take it in a boat
from columbia or someplace like columbia
all the way to iceland because it's like
a battery
they have free electricity they smelt it
with free electricity and it captures
the value of the electricity
and then they can ship the reynolds rap
anywhere in the world and make money
doing so
wow big coin and aluminum wow that
is uh that is fascinating that's
thinking outside the box now i have a
question for one of my lists
one of my listeners named mina uh she
says
she listens to the alt mba program uh
one of the what is
one of the dynamics of the program that
you believe allows it to get the results
and experience that it does
for its participants okay so the alt-mba
is the opposite of the
academic ladder we were talking about
there's no credentialing there's no
degree there's no exams
it's 30 days three hours a day it
changes people's lives
fundamentally rewires what we are
capable of
because it's all project work no gurus
it's simply
a group of people working together with
coaches sprinting
for a month and what you discover is
just
what you're capable of you discover what
it's like
to be surrounded by people who are on
your team and
when you're done you don't want to go
back to the old pace
and so that's why it works it works
because you have to be fully enrolled
you can't just try it out it's expensive
but it has a 97
completion rate because the people who
sign up for it are into it
they work with each other small group of
120 people
and it's a game changer so i'm not part
of it anymore but it's magical and i
strongly recommend it yeah okay now
we're into the final
uh three questions that i asked all my
guests first one
uh seth can you please provide in under
a minute
a four-dimensional non-abelian quantum
gravitational framework that
involves finding diagrams with no
divergent path integrals
i can do them with divergent but i can't
do anything all right all right
okay so you uh so into the impossible is
named after
sir arthur c clarke's uh famous third
law which i'll read in a second but his
first law is
any sufficiently advanced society is
indistinguishable from magic
his second law which appeals to you i'm
sure is for every expert
there's an equal and opposite expert and
his third law is the only way of
discovering the limits of the possible
is to venture a little way past them
into the impossible that's where i get
the name for the podcast
what obstacle or achievement seemed
impossible to a young seth godin
that now seems eminently doable because
you had the courage
and did it
so i worked with arthur and i love
hearing you quoting him back to me
um and that is a version of it which is
it was a long time before i got the
benefit of the doubt
and i don't think we offered the benefit
out to enough people i think we
restrict it to people based on race and
where they're from
but we also start with most people as
by default not getting the benefit of
the doubt and at 23
persuading arthur to trust me was really
really hard
and now i am stunned and a little scared
that i often get the benefit of the
doubt
uh and i wasn't sure it was ever going
to happen
uh it's really beautiful to hear from
you um so the next thing
is uh also related to sir arthur and
that involves a famous opening scene
from a 2001 a space odyssey where there
are primates and the savannahs of africa
and they encountered this mysterious
obelisk which then later makes an
appearance on the surface of the moon i
believe
and it's sort of meant to represent time
capsules or something meant to
be discovered when humanity is mature
enough intellectual enough has the
capacity
to really appreciate what they've
discovered i want to ask you
seth godin has a billion year long
lasting time capsule
what do you put in it what do you put on
it what do you do with it
this is like your your time capsule for
eternity
so is it to go back or is it to go
forward it's going forward so this will
be re
viewed in a billion years it'll be
opened
so uh don't say
we watched 2001 a little while ago the
the monkeys are terrible but leaving
that aside
one theory is that the monolith's job
is to uh somehow
trigger the mutation that taught
that ape to beat up the other apes and
turn us into humans and so it's poignant
in the sense that it took us out of the
garden of eden right
um i made a time capsule when i was in
third grade
the school put one together i have no
idea where it is now this is part of the
problem with time capsules is by the
time they're useful
they're gone and no one can remember
where they are
we tend to put the wrong thing in time
capsules
because we put in things that we think
are important that either are going to
stick around
and so they didn't need to be in the
time capsule or they're just not
important
and so i don't know
the clever answer here because a billion
years is too big a number for me to get
my arms around
and it's interesting to note you know as
you and i are talking in the middle
of a fraught week during a fraught year
ten years from now or what are we gonna
remember from this never mind a billion
and so i'm more focused on
are there a hundred people who i can
interact with today in a way that they
would be glad i did are there lights i
can turn on
is there somebody who needs the benefit
of the doubt and maybe i can offer to
them
and so forgive me for not playing the
time capsule game but
i'm much more interested in the other
one i want to just close with that um
and and and and a question i ask people
who are authors i say
um what uh what would you prefer uh a
hundred year
readers a year from now or one reader a
hundred years from now
and then i'll segue into a final thing
from carl sagan
i measure myself on what the people who
read my stuff teach other people
and if that cycle continues then it
feels to me like it's got
the basis of longevity the last thing
i'll conclude with i have the honor
carl uh of interviewing uh andrewian who
is carl sagan's widow and his daughter
sasha sagan who are both phenomenal
authors and i read this quote to them it
gave me
chills to read to them the words of
their late uh father and husband
carl sagan said what an astonishing
thing a book is it's a flat object made
from a tree with flexible parts in which
are imprinted lots of funny dark
squiggles but one glance at it and
suddenly you're inside the mind of
another person maybe long dead
for thousands of years across the
millennia an author is speaking to you
clearly
and silently inside your head writing is
perhaps the greatest
human invention binding together people
who never knew each other citizens of
distant epochs
books break the shackles of time a book
is proof that humans are capable of
working magic
i want to close with a question
tangential maybe to that which is that
one of my kids
i got a bunch of kids and uh and one of
them is working on something for the
nobel prize
in uh medicine uh called the never dying
pill
and that's uh and that would prevent you
from dying uh being killed
uh also um i wanna know would you take
my son elijah's uh never dying pill
or would you wanna live forever
essentially so that you could actually
have the voice of
seth godin in person perhaps a millennia
for now
yeah you and i have both read enough
science fiction to know that that
never ends well they never listen to the
scientists do they say
um seth godin author of the practice i'm
going to title this someday hopefully
i'll talk to you about constraints
because i think constraints are the most
important thing to becoming a good
scientist
um but i'm going to call this loose lips
sink ships
because i think the more you talk about
your work the less likely it's going to
come into the world i've learned that
from you
i want to thank you and uh hope that you
continue to receive
the blessings that you deserve you've
helped millions of people south
including me thank you so much
thank you this was super fun i love
talking science thanks for everything
i said be well
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
if you enjoyed this episode of into the
impossible with professor brian keating
please subscribe comment share and
review
watch on youtube listen on itunes
spotify
google player stitcher we appreciate
hearing from you
and are always open to your suggestions
for future episodes
for more information and to sign up for
professor keating's mailing list
go to briankeeting.com
follow professor keating on medium and
twitter at
dr brian keating dr brian keating
for more information on the clark center
go to
imagination.ucsd.edu
into the impossible is a production of
the arthur c clarke center for human
imagination
at the university of california san
diego in the division of physical
sciences
eric very director ryan heating
co-director
produced by ryan keating and stuart
[Music]
valco